some news away from the pandemic we've
got a new book that offers revelations
about the battle between Jeffrey Epstein
and the lawyer defending dozens of his
accusers in relentless pursuit my fight
for the victims of Jeffrey Epstein Brad
Edwards describes his decade-long
psychological struggle with the wealthy
financier who later died in jail facing
sex abuse charges
first on CBS this morning I spoke to
Edwards about his secret meetings with
Jeffrey Epstein for most of their nearly
11 year legal battle Brad Edwards fought
Jeffrey Epstein in the courtroom but in
2015 Edwards says Epstein suddenly
started reaching out personally by phone
it was always his idea to speak I never
had his phone number he would call me
and his phone would come up mysteriously
all zeroes on my cell phone
he says Epstein asked to meet at this
Starbucks in Boca Raton Florida starting
a series of secret rendezvous the early
meetings were him trying to figure out a
way to in his words divorce from me
caused me to stop prosecuting him we
were at the corner table right outside
Starbucks when he leaned over and said
to me Brad if you keep pursuing me this
way somebody's going to get hurt
Edwards had been after Epstein since
2008 when a client named Courtney wild
first came to him I know that I wanted
Jeffery in jail but that was all I knew
wild says she was recruited by Epstein
in 2002 at age 14 I was in middle school
I was this summer from 8th to 9th grade
wilde grew up in a Florida trailer park
just miles from Tony Palm Beach where
Epstein lived she was driven here to his
home paid $200 to massage him and then
as to recruit other young girls I've
always wanted answers like why they felt
like they could just sexually abuse so
many young girls and get away with it
went through jeffrey Epstein's house I
think that you could be talking about
500 women that he abused Jeffrey Epstein
molested dozens of children Edwards
would represent more than 30 of them and
lead the legal assault power control
that's it his recruitment of vulnerable
people for him to take advantage of
sexually was all lay a power trip that
is what drove him that he was the king
of the chessboard every room I was ever
in with him he thought he was the
smartest and he was going to immediately
prove it
Epstein boasted of powerful friends
including Bill Clinton Donald Trump and
Harvey Weinstein who Edward says was
once a guest at Epstein's Paris
apartment
Harvey Weinstein attempted to sexually
assault one of Jeffrey Epstein's main
girls
Epstein got mad about it and got in a
major blowout with Harvey Weinstein and
kicked him out of the place and in
Jeffrey's words kicked him out of the
country and never talked to him again
Epstein Edwards writes referred to
Harvey as a pig imagine that while
Epstein wooed Edwards he also allegedly
kept watch on him I saw the same car
following me it wasn't like somebody was
hiding it was meant for me to know
Epstein countersued the Florida lawyer
accusing him of malicious prosecution
when Edwards lost an early round in that
suit he says he was at risk of owing
Epstein's legal fees ten million dollars
when he realized he could do that he
called me and said hey look you will
bankrupt your entire family back off
what I'm very competitive to my clients
me and Brad kind of made a pact that we
were gonna be in it to the end in May of
last year
at the Starbucks in Boca Raton Edwards
says he and Epstein met for
would be the final time you could tell
he was just in a different frame of mind
nervous paranoid and it made me a little
uneasy thinking he may actually know
that there's a investigation brewing
behind his back
two months later Epstein was arrested by
federal agents and charged with sex
trafficking in August he died in prison
what if anything jail he was only scared
by losing his freedom so you know
believe that he was killed in prison
no I he committed suicide there's no
doubt in my mind you wrecked it you
struggled with it I felt like after ten
years of doing battle with him I got to
know him so well it wasn't he should die
this way the victims were deprived I was
deprived and it also just feels like he
left
laughing Edwards and Epstein settled
their lawsuit in 2018 as part of the
settlement
Epstein publicly apologized admitting
the charges he brought against Edwards
were an unreasonable attempt to damage
the attorneys reputation we'd like to
know too Edwards book is published by
gallery gallery books an imprint of
Simon & Schuster which is a division of
Viacom CBS gale of course this continues
to go on this case they are attempting
to create a fund for the victims from
the estate but that's an ongoing legal
battle boy Anthony that story was
fascinating on so many levels to me
number one I was I find it interesting
that Brad Edwards is so convinced that
he committed suicide when so many people
do not think Jeffrey Epstein took his
own life and number two I hear the
asking Kent's in the cameras how did
they shoot that interview could you
explain us a brief explanation cuz
you're in your office I don't know where
he was you're clearly having a
conversation together how did you guys
do that we had a lot of help Gail I shot
it here in my home he got him to sit
outside so that so the crew could could
be far enough away from him but we
wanted to get a really
I saw do and they did have decor did a
very nice job yeah it was very very very
well done very well done they're all so
interesting and when he said to you that
Epstein said to him if you keep pursuing
me somebody's gonna get hurt that's very
ominous also scary he took it as a
threat Brad Edwards took that as a
threat mm-hmm was it a very interesting
stuff it's clear that that more than
just Geoffrey Epstein's life was lost
when he died in prison a full accounting
of what happened was lost as well as a
very very powerful piece and it's how we
do journalism in the in the age of
coronavirus